four
three
two
hello hello
h3 podcast it's monday
april 4th
2 13
pm
yes we're 13 minutes late
not bad though
been worse
been more late a lot worse
[Applause]
we are missing love today look at we are
joined by the council of uh
not the council of ricks but like the
council of uh
[ __ ] pricks x oh yeah got em
plus selena who's never been on the
council welcome
new member of the council
[Music]
so love is gone
the love has left us
was i hearing some kind of angelic uh
zach was pumping in something nice
ominous really oh uh quickly thank you
to hellofresh spring has sprung and the
less time you spend in the kitchen the
better
that's why some of hellofresh's
delicious restaurant quality meals come
together in just
20 minutes get 16 free meals plus three
gifts with code h3tv16 at hellofresh.com
h3tv 16
and boy i am hungry i am hungry
yeah so i don't know if everyone's been
following we missed the show on friday
we were supposed to do a farewell to
love we were all gonna go to disney
right
and uh i got super sick on friday it's
been like an ongoing thing
it's been kind of just like this ongoing
thing man like we went to
how long was that i've been sick for
dude it's been like um like a month um i
guess it's been like
two
weeks
at least
because you were sick the week leading
into us going into vegas right yeah yeah
i had this sickness going to vegas
and then i was like okay i'm gonna take
these antibiotics
the doc i went to the doctor she said
take these antibiotics if you're not
feeling better i was feeling worse so i
took the antibiotics 10 day regimen
we go to vegas i'm doing the whole
antibiotics
feeling better actually
and then when i get home
when we get home on mond on sunday
sunday like last sunday
i started having like violent diarrhea
bro
which i guess is normal when you have uh
when you do antibiotics you know it can
happen that can happen
but then like on friday night
i was
puking and feeling nauseous
and it was it wasn't it was like
five diaries an hour did
you know
i told you i was like eli you got to buy
me diapers because i can't sleep
because there's just [ __ ] leaking out my
ass
and i'm proud to say i haven't warned
them but i do have diapers
i said buy me diapers bro 4xl
because like on friday night i was i
couldn't sleep because
if i lay i couldn't get off the toilet
and then the worst part about it
was that
apparently now they they or they thought
my [ __ ] was contagious which is like
make the whole thing even worse because
you think getting [ __ ] in your mouth
isn't that easy right
because that's how you apparently they
thought i had this [ __ ] called uh
c diff
yeah which i thought was called c dilf
at first which made me
more excited because i thought it made
me a death
but it's c diff so that's not right
that's less exciting
but anyway
yeah you think getting [ __ ] in your
mouth
isn't
is is hard to do but when you have
diarrhea like i had
it's flying fly because it was like
because i just i'm just gonna tell you
guys um because it's like non-stop okay
and then it's the kind where
you know it goes all the way up the side
of the bowl you know what i'm saying
unfortunately i do yeah right yeah
wendy knows what i'm talking about
um
and so but not only that like i got the
bidet going
there's water dripping down my legs
and i don't want to do apparently it
transfers in spores so if you put on the
if i put my you gotta put your at you
gotta dry your you gotta wipe your ass
right
certainly
it's just all over the place i mean i'm
washing my hands and stuff but
i'm washing my hands very well my hands
are about to [ __ ] you know fall off
my skin but
yeah friday night i i couldn't go like
five minutes without [ __ ]
and i was getting super dehydrated i
kept i was just drinking water drinking
water and then i started feeling super
nauseous so my body wouldn't um take the
liquid
and my stomach just started getting so
full and then i puked
a ton of liquid out and that's when i
got really into trouble because my body
got super dehydrated
i started like shaking my heart rate was
elevated anyway lena god bless her took
us took me to the uh to the urgent care
you know
oh boy
but when i checked in i had like a
elevated heart rate and my oxygen levels
were bad jesus
and
[Music]
so i had to get an iv
which was good you know i don't know ab
you can tell me or lena or one of you
all
as doctors in your family or you both
went to like pre-med school or some [ __ ]
is there supposed to be [ __ ] when
they put the iv in your
arm how much air is there supposed to be
in that [ __ ] because i don't
think there's supposed to be air in that
i don't believe there's supposed to be
any if i'm not mistaken yeah because
there was like a pretty like good chunk
of air they shot into my veins
oh and then you said they lost your
blood too right yeah then i lost my
blood
that's crazy
sorry
they lost my blood dan
morby is hanging around
in the shadows
is marvius a vampire is that the [ __ ] i
believe he is a vampire i'm not even
worse than i thought i didn't know it
was a vampire thing
morbius morbius
yeah so i took a whole bag of uh iv with
up with some added bonus of air into my
veins that doesn't sound right
i then another nurse came out
in chat but you'd be dead
no guys no i looked it up you can i
trust me no not one drop of air kills
you guys okay okay
there was air in it trust me and then
another
nurse came in i said is it normal for
there to be some air he's like yeah
there's gonna be some air he's like just
not the whole iv you know tube that's
too much i was like oh okay
okay
no more than i didn't want to ask the
girl the lady who did it
oh the other crazy thing is like i had i
wasn't peeing all day because i was like
so dehydrated there's just no fluid in
me
and then so
i got the iv
and then i did like a urine and stool
sample and i swear and i you guys y'all
seen ever seen a human feces like that
before
yeah ethan sent a picture and it was
highly unusual
i'll just say the least i'll describe it
if you guys watch ninja turtles it looks
like the ooze they gave the turtles
powers that's the best way to describe
it i wish i could show it to you guys
all because it's i don't want to
consider it necessarily gross as it's
just like
interestingly it's i mean it's [ __ ] it
was pretty gross
broccoli broccoli cheddar soup from a
soup plantation yeah yes actually yes
look just like that wait i i wish i
could show you guys just because i had
never seen a human feces like this
before
freshly fresh paste though
i mean you guys have seen it so you can
confirm
yeah
let me see
i just want to give you the best
possible
i mean this is basically right on what
do you guys think
it was a little bit darker than that
but um by the way i hope not far off by
the way i just ruined pesto for
thousands yeah
[Laughter]
now that's that's pretty accurate
little bits of yellow in it basically
yeah
i wanted to i got this new phone to make
everything more complicated annoying
i was so worried about like spreading it
to ela
that
i watched my phone
which has cracks and my phone died
wait that's how your phone died yeah
you just poured water on it
intentionally well they're all
waterproof now
water resistant
and so well i i wanted to i was trying
to sanitize everything right yeah
and it well it died
[ __ ] what a weekend dude
i [ __ ] hate
changing phones i don't care i would
rather i'll have a 20 year old phone and
never change phones like i got the new
iphone which is great and fine and
whatever i just i don't give a [ __ ] it's
fine it's just like now i'm locked out
of instagram by the way because this
happened the last time my two-step is on
the old phone it goes just log into your
account and approve the login it's like
yeah that phone's dead
the two steps on that phone it's all
[ __ ] so now i got to set a picture to
facebook of me holding up a sign with
some random numbers being like yo it's
me in the hopes that
yeah is if anybody out there at
instagram can help me
we also need ian to get verified too
right
right ian
you ever send that letter
yeah i did i sent the letter i didn't
get a response
definitely he did he did write an email
yes yeah i said i said that's all it was
complicated that's it i followed my yeah
that was part of your that was your part
of the bargain
thank you
but
i i was shocked you know i've been
pooping into the oh this looks right
this kind of looks just like it did i
think
that's yeah
like this yeah
maybe
is a little bit dark the one on the
smaller picture on the top right i would
say it was like that
uh
that darkness this one yeah that
you think it was that dark it was pretty
dark yeah
well anyway look like an egg drop soup
like from chinese restaurant with the
soup comparisons i'm never gonna be able
to eat super well anyway i was trying to
send the picture to my friend when i uh
i started i opened my new phone there's
no photos so the first picture i got on
my phone was the picture of my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
which is right here i'm looking at it
and i wish i just wish i could show it
like i feel like i could because it's
it's a medical intrigue right
it's not that dark dad i'm looking at it
okay well it's your poop
i'd say that last plate was pretty
accurate that looks like it
did you just tweet it
actually just tweet it and be like
who's a fan of pesto
actually i'll i will tweet it okay
because there that's not a violation of
anything
it might be
twitter you can you can post feces on
twitter can you put it's a medical i
don't care ban me i don't like twitter
anyway okay
we posted my [ __ ] on there
yeah
actually maybe posted on the uh
podcast one day
should we post it on the podcast one
yeah probably keep your yeah people
didn't they're not looking to see my
[ __ ] right now yeah
so if you guys want to
market uh market sensitive content yeah
yeah do like uh do it not safe for life
or work filter or whatever yeah
okay i'll i'll link like a immigrant
link or something
there's a thing built into twitter where
it'll blur it yeah sensitive content and
they have to opt in to see just say
warning [ __ ] human human feces right you
know
people know what they're getting yeah so
people watching you want to see
let me open chat for this
i gotta see what y'all are
by the way we have a lot to get to we
have a we have a whole memorial we did
for love who's home safely now by the
way yes he landed back in sweden about
an hour ago
he eat the title of today ethan was in
the hospital not clickbait this time
that was a joke when i sent that title
there i thought it was funny okay
i don't know if it's gonna work before
we're being like
in the hospital
ethan wasn't in the hospital
i'm not sure how to do the not safe for
work thing i just post the damn thing
and should i pesto anyone
but
okay i i just i'm looking at jack
because i actually
i i personally was just
i think you all should check it out
because
it's not what you think it really it's
crazy
all right i'm gonna post it pesto anyone
and just post it no no no no no say
warning you oh well i guess the warning
doesn't matter yeah it doesn't don't do
warning don't do pet that's too gross
how do you block it how do you block the
thing i i've i know there's a way to do
it because i've seen i've come across
those posts where it's it's all blurred
and you have to click on it to see it
i've never done it myself though so i
don't know
i'm looking for i keep keep working on
that yeah yeah i'm not trying to
traumatize anyone who's not google it
the thing was you know
i'm still having these uh diarrheas by
the way
oh you are yeah that's why i'm i mean
the doctor's gonna call me this evening
and
go over the results but
i don't know because
my condition is not improved really
i mean friday night i was dehydrated and
like dying you know literally but other
than that
are you
wearing the diapers no i'm not wearing a
diaper no
no
um
but what shocked me about this photo
that you guys are going to see in a
minute
because i was making when you drop these
into a toilet
the color dilutes
right it's just kind of yellowy greeny
but when i saw it in the actual
container they give you to [ __ ] in
i was just like
whoa dude i am [ __ ] sick
[Laughter]
we were
we were out to dinner when you dropped
that oh no uh that photo well it's like
we were dying laughing at it
thankfully it wasn't italian but
still
unfortunate timing nobody was eating
pesto
yeah i think i figured it out i'm gonna
i'm gonna give it a go
all right
all right it's up
it is up
all right it's up guys y'all go up there
and tell me what's wrong with you
well the thing is see diff
apparently your poop is green when you
have it too so
but
so
did we not hear that you don't have it
so we talked to the lab today they won't
i gotta talk to a doctor but apparently
it's negative for
parasitic
or bacterial infections so
seems like it's not the diff
that's lighting up because they're
seeing it now
all right i'm checking out chat we're
seeing
oh my god
it worked oh my god i just saw it neon
oh my god
legit looks like pesto
green ramen i regret looking
let's see
trying to get the snap judgment on the
on the feces here
um
it's glowing yeah it's super neon
which is weird guys because when i took
this dump
my stomach had been empty for like two
days straight
all right so what the [ __ ] is that color
from
stomach acid and stuff probably think so
i don't know i'm just guessing stomach
bile yeah people are saying it's like
garlic butter dip some breadstick in
that you think
yeah but uh let's see
it's even a bowl like they serve at the
restaurant yeah
they give you this kind of uh
tray to put over the toilet bowl to [ __ ]
i've never done a stool sample so
first she gave me a stick she's like you
just want to scoop the feces with this
little uh
you know the stick they used to push
your tongue down i was like what
because you see what my [ __ ] looks like
yes i have i was like how much do you
need
to be here for a while
watch this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
um
yes yeah
let's
see [ __ ] dude
people are wanting to buy it for a
thousand that's vile radioactive
yep
all accurate somebody's saying it shreks
after birth
some people don't even think it's real
someone said put it in reverse image
search
i took that myself my friend surreal as
it gets yeah
i saw some people saying salsa verde
yeah it does
ruin salsa verde for me too
that's not bruce's [ __ ] my friend that
came from my own ass on friday night
i saw someone say that calls chernobyl
[Laughter]
right
so if there's anyone out there that can
tell me what's wrong with me
based on the
the look of my [ __ ]
i always imagine when some when the you
bring a
sample to a lab there's
they act like there's all this crazy
science going on but it's just one dude
that swirls it in his
mouth just a little taste test and then
he can tell what's going on
i don't i don't like that
yeah yeah someone says you missed a
little bit on the left yeah no [ __ ] i
was [ __ ]
surprised that much went in the bowl
so what what was that process like did
you like put it under the toilet or how
did that go
oh so the bowl just sits on top of the
toilet seat
there's only like a couple inches
between [ __ ] and the bottom of that
plastic there
you know
right
so there you guys have it it's all on
twitter now
uh on podcast twitter
somebody says definitely c diff
c diff is yellow and has a distinct
smell
okay pamela i didn't notice or recall a
smell but they said it didn't have an
infection so
but let's see what the doctor says
they said by the way guys they're saying
parasite they said no parasite no
infection
just regular old duty ass
tonight
but you know i can't eat i haven't eat
i'm ta all up all i'm eating is
probiotic yogurt
and [ __ ] bananas and like eggs and
white and like matzah that's it it seems
good easy on the stomach it's the only
thing i can
keep down but i'm i'm on like 300
calories a day here
insane
so
i don't know what's going on
but
i'm pretty sure the antibiotics just
destroyed my
you took them as prescribed though it
sounds like right like it's just like a
regular regimen of well so she gave me
she gave me um
she gave me 20 pills for 10 days to a
day right and because we were going to
vegas i said you know [ __ ] it i just i'm
going to take 10 today
and 10 the next day
i'm kidding
like what
yeah no i took them as prescribed of
course okay took two a day
for ten [ __ ] days
and i came out more [ __ ] up than i
went in
[ __ ] well there you go
so i don't know guys
i'm just so tired of being sick all the
time
and then before this there was a culvert
test so i was sleeping in the basement
what the [ __ ] dude down bad
now i'm [ __ ] pesto sauce
unbelievable
i got diapers
for excel my friends
i said ela buying diapers
and the biggest size they got
for men
[Music]
the cap out of 4x out huh
i don't know
i don't know what you bought but
i'll check them out tonight
you know
yeah
i wish i had a tapeworm
at least you know what it is
you ever wonder if having a tapeworm is
kind of good
because it makes you skinny yeah the
implication here does anybody that do
tapeworm diets is that a thing
i've heard people say that but i i have
always just assumed as a joke i don't
know if people actually do that
i feel like it's got to be a real thing
i i mean it seems like a bad idea
tapeworm diet weight loss risk side
effects
yeah i'm saying it looks like it's
no
real thing or at least may have been
like a long time ago here what are the
dangers of a tapeworm diet
well a tapeworm attaches itself to your
intestines and feeds off your body's
nutrients
and grows by reproducing
okay that sounds like a
bad
one of the biggest dangers with a
tapeworm is that you can't control where
it attaches itself
tapeworm can attach itself to other
organs
or tissues oh good
okay
i'm seeing people in the chat say it's
real
oh god that's that's disgusting it's so
[ __ ] disgusting dude [ __ ] egg
and then they gotta pull like a 20-foot
ass
string of worm out your ass dude
it tastes like beef jerky
oh
no
why would you do that zach
dip keemstar can be dipping that
a fork with some syrup
[Music]
but you know what
i was in poor health but i did have well
wishes from my friends and that that
makes all the difference
[Music]
for example keemstar
tweeted out
he was quick boy that was that same
night man
i m that must have been like immediately
after i posted it isn't it
yeah i believe it was like roughly an
hour after like before any anyone else
saw you know game stars on that [ __ ]
i don't know what you're talking about
well he actually got a lot of likes
that's actually sad
i mean for him
let's pray it's a mental health facility
he said so
epic
giving me can't wait to report on your
death vibes which of course i'm not
dying
but
he did say that to total biscuit after
his cancer diagnosis
pretty incredible man yeah guys like
he's really something in he
well his next tweet pretty much had the
same energy oh i haven't seen this one
if you read the caption it says
i stopped by one of my biggest haters
funeral today just to make sure that he
was dead
wait this is wait when did he tweet this
this was shortly after the one of you in
the hospital oh he wants me to die now
bro what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] dude
huh
dude
that's [ __ ] amazing
hell nah bro
this man thinks about me so much
i mean this tweet is hilarious i'll give
it up
well dressed to the t
you know keemstar come to my funeral in
jorts
yeah a rainy day he's got like a
see-through umbrella phase cap george
face cap
pull up in one of them some red hoodie
bikes
a dirt bike a third bike a quad with a
yeah with a 18 year old
in beef jersey actually you know what
he's going to roll up with a 17 year old
color his assistant yeah
so it's you
know why are you so cute when you talk
[ __ ]
i don't know keemstar
yo he's crazy i didn't know he was
straight wishing on my death
by the way you got to pull up that
boogie one too because that that boogie
one was i'm sorry but
like i got home you know my phone died
so i i wasn't able to be on my phone
i got home
installed twitter did all that and this
and boogie night boogie nine
two nine eight eight
now i haven't muted
but when you have someone muted
when they at you and uh quote tweet you
it still shows up so
i had to unfollow him after this because
i honestly just can't deal with seeing
his tweets anymore
so if you're wondering why look at this
[ __ ] he goes
he goes apparently ethan's in the
hospital i know a lot of people don't
like this guy
but i really wish he'd take better care
of himself
mother dude he can't even sit on he
can't even wish someone well without
sitting on the fence he's like i hope
you live
he's like you know i know a lot of
people don't like him but i hope he
lives it's like can you not sit on a
[ __ ] fence when wishing someone well
at least
this is the first thing i see i know a
lot of people don't like this guy
[ __ ] you dude
dumbass such a weirdo why bother even
tweeting that
who doesn't like me keemstar
you know
who doesn't like me buggy
there was an epic tweet
i was like what is twitter
yeah this guy's kind of a piece of [ __ ]
but i don't think he should die
yeah well some many people think he
should die but i think he should get
well
it's pretty incredible people make fun
of boogie for being like a fence sitter
but
this is pretty awesome
many people wish you would die
man
but i am kind of curious about
the amount of likes kim star got
because
he usually doesn't get this many likes
were people clowning on him or
i saw a lot of people clowning on him
the top i think the top comment was uh
he lives in your head rent free
yeah i'm getting treated in his hat red
free
i'm getting an iv drip
he's planning my funeral
he's planning what to wear to my funeral
okay [ __ ] he's fantasizing about
attending my funeral bro
got a whole eulogy yeah he's probably
he's got a eulogy plan
i mean he's probably even got a he's
probably wondering how to approach ila
she's too old yeah yeah
she's too old obviously
yeah
hila remembers uh 9 11 so
and she's too old that's that's
it's not a joke you know the crazy you
know so keemstar is dating like this 18
year old girl named brantley
the crazy thing about this girl is oh oh
did you wait do we have the thing where
she challenged like ila to a boxing
match and all this crazy [ __ ]
yeah that's in the next section it's
just since we're on the topic of
keemstar
[Music]
oh yeah
brantley brantley
called out ila to fight this shit's
man
real quick
i have an announcement from my assistant
brantley she would like to say something
um out hilah klein in the ring if you
guys don't mind
on the undercard of uh keem versus hate
she's dead serious like she is dead this
is about your fight right
yeah
yeah what the [ __ ] are they talking
about
they want to fight ela on your fight
well just yeah no in general yeah
because in general
because they were saying he should box
me because he was so mad at me
he just hates me and then he's like i'll
only box ethan ethan's the only person
on the box
and which led to this
you know people say that gila klein is
axe military
um you know she she was part of the
israel armed forces or whatever and
that's good like that's good like please
please keep talking that smack that
nobody's talking he's like she was in
the military therefore she's talking
smack
she was a secretary bro come on you know
everything about me and my wife don't
act like you're surprised by any of
these details
she would beat my assistant that's what
we need we need her to have some
confidence going into this to actually
agree to it because uh
brantley will knock her out cold
yeah maybe maybe brantley maybe should
next uh challenge the queen of england
maybe she'll have a yeah as likely a
chance i don't think they let you in the
boxing ring with braces
right that's against regulation baby are
you allowed to box with braces
i'm not sure probably a bad idea yeah
go [ __ ] yourself you stupid piece of
[ __ ] abs
that was dude oh we gotta get to that
so um
apparently anyway my thing about this
girl brantley is that once they break up
which inevitably is gonna happen
keemstar i just want you to know that
brantley is definitely gonna come into
our dms
like she gonna go straight to ab
and every dumb thing you've done every
time you raised your voice every time
you scared her right every time you uh
gave alcohol to one of her underage
friends in her basement or whatever the
[ __ ] goes on down there
huh yo do you get like um
greek
greek temple vibes from keemstar's
basement
what do you mean by that keep thinking
well i think i know but
[Music]
i'm just saying bro
when you're surrounded by uh young
uh potentially under the age of 21 year
old girls and you're the centerpiece of
your house is a cool uh
bar in your basement with uh pinball
machines and video games
you know
probably not some probably some illegal
stuff going on there
but she's gonna she's gonna go straight
to a b and tell him everything kim stars
though just be prepared for that i mean
that's just guaranteed what's up baby i
said there's another message brantley
left at the end of that clip if you want
to listen it's at the very end like 50
second mark
oh sure yeah i'd love to
i want people to understand that like we
are dead serious like this is not a joke
we've got to absolutely want to box
it's giving me we don't care vibes wait
what was that
we've got absolutely one two bucks
what'd she say if he won't take on keem
she can take on me or something
or he could take on one of those yeah
she could take on her oh is she
challenging me
giving me duck dynasty vibes
exactly dude it's the same thing
ah
yeah so shout outs to my uh good friends
keemstar and buggy
for mish wishing me well
but we actually have so much to get to
uh we're already uh 35 minutes we should
do our so before that i just want to say
guys um there is a sale going on on
teddy fresh i mentioned on
wednesday was going to be happening we
extended it
for our podcast viewers
in case you guys forgot i wanted to add
an extra day because we didn't get to
tell you guys about it on friday when it
was live
teddy fresh friends and family
30 off the whole website live right now
come on guys go check it out
teddyfresh.com
now's the chance to get that drippy drip
at 30 off we almost never have sales so
here's a good time to get
some items you've had your eyes on so
teddyfresh.com
30 off the whole dang thing it gets
automatically applied at the checkout
you don't need a coupon code or anything
check it out man there's a lot of cool
stuff there
there's actually a lot of cool stuff on
the website right now color block
hoodies
looney tunes
velour sets
jeans bro
look at these drip this dripping i love
this piece so nice
and black
and cream
uh give all love to the queen ela
who've been doing so much by the way
since i've been sick
not worthy this is one of my favorite
search of all time too thirty percent
off
love this colors dude come on bro come
on
come the [ __ ] on
we have a promo graphic what is this tv
yeah just a promo graphic oh it was
extended oh we got a promo we got a new
promo graphic you guys oh
hey
anyways head on over teddyfresh.com
check it out thank you
all right let's think we have two
sponsors let's take them real fast
curology
it's a game-changing custom skin care
made
for you by turmer
dermatology provider they'll create a
custom prescription cream for your
specific goals whether that's tackling
acne clogged pores skin texture dark
spots fine lines or something else you
start by taking a short online quiz
and uploading photos
and if it's a good fit they'll ship you
your formula right to your door it even
has your name on it
on the bottle
i've actually been using uh curology i
love the surface
uh you take photos of your skin
close-ups real nasty close-ups these are
all
nastiness you know what i'm saying
blackheads dark spots fine lines
and then the dermatology provider custom
makes a formula for you sends it out you
get a
face wash
facial moisturizer and the uh
dermatology provided cream
and i gotta say besides the cream which
is obviously amazing the face wash
and the moisturizer i am living for
these they're so
light
and they clean my skin without like
stripping of all the oil
the moisturizer super light and it dries
and it doesn't make my skin feel oily
it's a really great product i i use it
i love it i really do um
let's see they do all these kinds of
stuff here
uh
the dark spots
the acne
the this the that oh here it is
acne clogged for skin texture dark spots
fine lines or something else there you
go see caught them all
yeah
get started with curology just like i
did for a free 30-day trial at
curology.com h3 just pay five bucks
for shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com
slash h3 to start your free 30-day trial
cancel anytime
prescription is subject to consultation
thank you thank you to curology baby
and finally stamps.com
who doesn't love stamps time is mine
don't waste either with repeated trips
to the uh post office
[Music]
i literally just thought about how
keemstar was wishing i died and laughed
i forgot it was just
this occurred to me that he actually
come with that heat
this is crazy brother he hates me that
much man
uh
oh god it's hot in here you guys
can you hit that ac
oh [ __ ] bro
stamps stamps
amps stamps let's get to the stamps
all right let me start from the top time
is money people
don't waste time with repeated trips to
the post office with stamps.com you can
skip the trip and focus on how to take
your small business to the next level
stamps.com lets you print official
postage right from your computer and
save you money in the process so you can
spend less time at the post office and
more time making your customers happy
uh dan you're ollie uses stamps right
yeah she does for her small business she
runs from home uh her art business she
sells prints and
that kind of stuff posters and stickers
and all that kind of thing and yeah
she's able to just print all the postage
from her desk
you've got the way it right there huh
they give you a scale yeah it's got a
little scale plugs into the computer and
you put whatever it is you're trying to
ship on there weighs it
a little printer prints out the postage
slap it on an envelope wow give it to
the post mantis and let me get this
straight
the deals are better
yes and you don't even have to go to the
post office they'll come and get it
they'll come and get it so let me ask
you dan why would anybody not use
stamps.com they would have to be an
absolute
fool or not watch the show one of those
those are the only two explanations
only vladimir putin doesn't use
stamps.com
they do not use the united states postal
service in uh the russian federation
that would not be an effective uh
mail courier for him
but you know you can get discounts you
can't find anywhere else that's 40 off
usps rates and 76 percent off ups wow so
if you're shipping
uh packages
any letter any package any size anywhere
you want
stamps.com is going to get you there
it's great
i love stamps stop overpaying for
shipping with stamps.com
sign up
at stamps.com h3tv with a special offer
that includes a four week trial free
postage and a digital skill no long-term
commitment or contracts
that's stamps.com h3tv thank you thank
you to our beautiful sponsors please
consider supporting one of them
thank you
so there you have it
[Music]
all right
i guess we should move on now
i guess so
oh thank you i wanted to see some
wait what is this
i wanted this oh [ __ ] i gotta pull up
the uh tweet we did of my human feces
bro
800 comments 800 likes is there any
interesting comments under that
uh not that i saw i just thought it was
interesting that there's so many
comments and uh
the comments and likes were almost uh
stepping in tandem yeah so we're getting
ratioed
your [ __ ] ratio well my [ __ ] is getting
ratioed yeah it's a highly engaging
tweet
ratioed well i'm glad we able we were
able to get that uh sensitive
content warning there
but uh
you know i wanted to come in and do the
show just because i'm just sitting at
home anyway
i don't know i was considering taking
the whole week off and just resting but
when i'm just driving and sitting and
talking
and the show must go on man pass up and
work you know what
yes i i kim kardashian was resounding
people just don't want to get their ass
up
even if there's [ __ ] coming out of it at
work i'm just blasting out your ass all
day
we gotta do the show man people rely on
this show
life goes on man life goes on
and on and on right on do a poll how
many people have looked at this [ __ ] i'm
just curious by percentage
i've looked at it
but maybe we should talk about love
being gone first i think that uh is the
most urgent
we have a memorial between your legs
oh yeah so basically love is gone
love is gone again he was here for three
months we all loved love we love love
you're wearing a love hat all right
everybody
he's probably almost home now i was like
he could probably join the council by
the time he gets home
uh
yeah uh he said
it's like a two two and a half hour
drive from the airport once he finally
got back to sweden because he lives in
an enchanted forest in the middle of
nowhere
you know
he's such a
such a cornerstone of this community he
does so much
when i realized that the h3 community
was making our mark on the place
which is reddit's
interactive canvas that they do for uh
april fools
love is spearheading the whole movement
he did he took control he took command
he is our general
we follow him
when we started we started to slip for
like a half hour and it was because
we're out to eat and loves like i can't
go away for a half hour this is what
happened
by the way that dinner y'all went to
look nice where'd you guys go
boa's steakhouse oh
classy
let me ask you this how did it compare
to the vegas steakhouse
it wasn't as good because you weren't
there you and ila
yeah it you know it we ate like pretty
late like late i think later than we did
in vegas and it was richer and it
personally speaking it [ __ ] my stomach
up more the vegas one no no no the the
boa yeah
i i've been to boa it's nice but that
vegas one was crazy i don't know why
that just like nailed it for me
that was good but okay very good
mr company your guys is coming yeah i
missed you guys it looked fun having you
you could see all you guys out there but
we made a little um
you know we made a little video in honor
of love
time here in america so here it is
love in america
nine minutes holy [ __ ] all right
it's uh all right everything on friday
what
it's a segment as well like we we
basically came in on friday and filmed a
segment
because there we canceled the show and
this is what we were gonna do
on the show on friday
so
it's a little more involved than just a
tribute video you'll see so love my
friend what was it i forget
what do you mean the segment idea
that we were gonna do
uh it's like a
a quiz of his americaness how much he's
acquired while in here
so he was here for three months and we
are going to test his aptitude how
american how americanized has he become
in those three months i i was i was
impressed but he was an american weeaboo
we had established already right
cam you're the one that lost your
roommate there how are you feeling
honestly it yeah it really has been a
heavy uh 24 hours um he left behind for
me he gave me this gift um of his
pewdiepie g fuel
wow wow his most treasured possession
yeah and uh i mean he was he was
honestly like we we bonded like brothers
over the past few months and i'm really
actually genuinely very
sad that he's gone and i can't wait for
him to come back because he was a great
roommate and we
he introduced me a lot of cool content
because he's always watching cool
youtubers so
i know he'll be back soon though so i
can't wait for that and i hope i can
live with him then too
well we're doing everything we can
to bring him uh bring him out and and if
all of us fails
um
we'll just all move to sweden
we'll do it the other way around yeah i
want to go to sweden now
and live with him there he wants to come
here what are we going to do we can all
anyway here let's let's watch the video
and uh
see what you guys think
any minute now here it comes
here we go and now the video you've all
been waiting for here it is drum roll
please
drum roll please
uh ethan couldn't make it today
okay we're not doing it doesn't want to
do full screen eh
we can zoom on it
just refresh the page
[ __ ] [ __ ]
google drive ladies and gentlemen
quality product
here we go all right everybody uh ethan
couldn't make it today because he saw a
trailer for morbius and he has been
violently [ __ ] ever since we don't
know why
but we're still gonna go on we're doing
a segment it's called the freedom games
and we are joined
by the legends it's mr langhorne love
everybody give a round of applause
how are you partner love is leaving
america in a couple days we're all
devastated
but we're hoping he's learned some
lessons about what it means to be a true
american while being here yes sir
so we have a series of challenges to
test love's knowledge of being a true
patriot and at the end love will be an
honorary patriot himself so number one
let's hear your best american accent all
right partner anyone here from arizona
because i dun gun recently caught a big
darn alligator
and that boy was
oh was that big that dun gong thing was
over three meters in length
god damn rascal oh the notes are coming
out
yeehaw pardner giddy up doggy rotten cop
poke goes down the smoother then uh
half court star spells perilla all right
and now love you're being transported to
the baseball diamond oh america's
favorite pastime
oh the one-handed swing great technique
i've never seen that before
[Music]
[Applause]
home run baby home run oh and love look
like you're in a country bar we're gonna
have to see your best moves all right
all right partner
[Music]
oh he's injured ladies and gentlemen and
now he is in the doctor's office
hopefully they can help you out here
comes the doctor uh it looks like you
got a big boo boo there so i'm gonna
prescribe you one advil and that will be
five thousand dollars five thousand dong
what the heck
there's a crippling medical bill for
what the hecking dog now love you are
going to school
oh it's time to pick out your outfit oh
oh today's class these are all very nice
this reminds me of someone like scarce
maybe not that one this is a bit too red
too swedish yes that's swedish
what about this right here
oh
bulletproof
the great selection love and what a
fantastic bulletproof vest from the prop
department and now the teacher is going
to be coming in to give you a lesson
hello i'm professor dan
here's a couple quick questions about
america
multiple choice hey you just paid 25
dollars for access to the golden corral
buffet line
do you a load up your tray with a
sensible portion and enjoy a classic
american no
demand to speak to the manager 25 for a
buffet are you insane this is outrageous
start throwing things around or c load
up your tray with 12 pounds of mac and
cheese and ham that's been sitting under
a heat lamp for six hours gorge yourself
until you're on the verge of vomiting c
that's right like we could work you know
i would have accepted b as well yeah i
mean b
was good b or c yeah either one yeah as
long as he didn't definitely not a yeah
definitely yeah last question here
you're working your 14th day in a row at
an amazon warehouse tomorrow is your day
off but you're not are you guys trying
to get him to come to america or never
[ __ ] want to be here again damn i'm
just
you know
my friends
they offer another 12-hour shift do you
a report your employer to the
authorities for unfair labor practices
organize your co-workers and launch a
unit unionization vote c tell him to
[ __ ] off uh and quit and you can easily
find another job or d say okay and do it
knowing there'll be no consequences d
that's right that's the american way
right there this man has a mere
right love and now we're going to be
transported to the war room
oh what sort of mysteries are hidden in
here it's cool oh and looks like
oh it's a mysterious button what will
you do love i think you're gonna don gon
press this red dung on the bottom right
here
oh
and you just launched a drone strike on
a poor unsuspecting country no problem
hell yeah brother the american way my
friend
and now to finish it off we're being
transported to a classic yeah you got
okay you guys turn this into like some
kind of political statement all right
that's all okay
yeah that's true we did aoc is a cr is
uh laughing and crying carl tuckerson is
crying and spitting right now
[Music]
bring out the food ladies and gentlemen
classic texas barbecue and an apple pie
and a couple coors lights
like a true american oh like a true
american yes
oh look at that technique
oh
oh
oh
nice and darn gone barbecue right there
dango no
so what you got what am i gonna do
dungar
okay and y'all from arizona catching
gators over here dungan gators in
arizona
i have some non-garden good papaya
shotgun that silver bullet my friend
let's send it off right do i have any
partners that want to join me
oh yeah
[Music]
look at that technique
he's slammed it
[Music]
true american ladies and gentlemen
true patriot right there that's a real
american right there
dungarn yeah
[Music]
all right love i think you uh passed the
test with flying colors so let's bring
out his prize oh
it's a table of chicks i gotta expose
you guys that chick-fil-a sauce is still
there man he didn't take oh we have to
ship it are you going to ship it yeah
his uh yeah yeah his his baggage is like
one of the first things when love came
here he was literally cruising around
with a bottle of chick-fil-a
putting it on everything yeah
the man fell in love with chick-fil-a
sauce
young garden chicken chick-fil-a sauce
we don't have this back where i come
from six bottles of homophobic sauce for
you there
now love actually before you before you
finish we actually have one more special
gift for you let's go ahead and bring
that out for him let's bring that out
well i'll be darned god dang darn that
is that ain't that a whip gun garden wow
this is the new love bot my friend
look at that it comes with
such features as
a pokemane framed photo a swedish fish
aquarium wow bottle of g fuel
and a g fuel holder
dark garnet dog a custom swedish
meatball dispenser swedish flags the
custom swedish ikea boots a special
button
i wouldn't hit that button love because
it plays copyrighted music abba in fact
a swedish
icon
[Music]
it's the instant claim button
used for emergencies darn garnet darn it
the fika for life license plate
what do you think love love bought two
love but two don garnet i'm gonna whip
this hope
i finna whip this hole
now we come to the end i think love pass
with flying colors
true
patriots
honorary american
thank you all now i love you
it's time for you to head back
unfortunately
time to hit the duster trail see you all
partners
[Applause]
oh
sad just to see him dissolve out of
there oh [ __ ] what's
up oh yeah i made it let me get out and
hug you yeah yeah yeah i'm ready
[Music]
now that's a hug
[Music]
you guys were dogs from the minute you
see
did you see how cam and love embraced
there yep kindred spirits i actually got
to see that again
okay i made it let me get out and hug
you yeah yeah i'm really really bored
finally
see ya
what's up damn this remix is getting me
emotional no that's a hug
look at that oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
dude
i got it
he's here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
emotional actually
well done guys
well done
and a bon voyage to love
gone but not forgotten
we'll be back soon that was emotional
man
and oddly enough good timing i'm just
receiving word that he's home now and
he's going to join soon oh
look at that
good time speak of the speak of the
people speak of the fica speaker the
feek he's
what a timing yeah this is not planned
this is pure coincidental the man has
got off the plane
driven home
he's been flying for how long love you
look like you've been traveling for a
while how are you feeling
yo what's up everyone i have no clue
what's going on hang on we gotta balance
your audio a little bit a little quiet
[Music]
you're you're coming in quiet
all right i don't know you gotta you
gotta mix your own audio again
oh i have to
uh oh
you can't hear me at all no i can't it's
just quiet it's getting better now
hello
who is that on our end or his end dan
it's on his end i turned it up as much
as i could over here but
we can hear you it's just a little quiet
is this better yes yes way better yes
all right how are you feeling i'm
tired dude yeah yeah you look tired damn
but you got home safely
you're back we just watched the the uh
the memorial did you get any of that oh
really yeah we just finished it the
timing was insane
that is weird it was beautiful it's
powerful
oh i'm glad you liked it i'm glad you're
wow powerful moving
and the flight was 17 hours by the way
17 hours
you had a layover too right
yeah well the the first flight was 14
then a two hour layout layover
then another three hour flight so that's
around 17 i think holy smokes and then
you had like another two hour drive
right oh right a two and three hour
drive oh that's right
well love your you're back home you're
safe and sound once you get some sleep
you know well i'm gonna hang around okay
i don't want to miss the show yeah yeah
this guy you you believe this guy
i have this thing i have not missed one
show since i started working well damn
bro
kim kardashian would be proud yeah kim
kardashian
she was talking about you man
yeah you're [ __ ] asking i'm sure she
did well we just did this whole memorial
and now you're here so what the [ __ ] you
we've ever got a chair for you now i
mean
[ __ ]
i'll just see my cell phone
since you're here anyways i'm receiving
reports that uh our logo is under attack
on the uh place yeah so we need you to
we need our general we need you to get
to work on the place please yeah okay i
definitely will yeah
so is this still up okay i was kind of
scared because ethan you
you're
i don't want you to make war with our
neighbors we have what have i done
well i just want to make sure that you
know that oh jesus
oh my god
you're breaking up
so for those who don't know there's a
thing going on let me just go to reddit
maybe i can help get you some
some new soldiers love yes please
so on reddit they do this thing
sometimes on april fools
where they have a live canvas
why can't i see the live canvas here i'm
on the place subreddit uh you're on the
old reddit layout is why it doesn't show
on there you need to go to new reddit
click here
new reddit all right i can't do this
you got uh
uh it should be on the right hand side
if you scroll down a little bit place a
tile maybe that'll help
yeah all right here we go it's loading
so
there is an interactive canvas this
thing is insane
and what you see here is a bunch of
pixels that is just live
being edited by hundreds of thousands of
people
oh my god did people really remove total
biscuits who would do that
i mean everybody gets attacked
constantly it said rest in peace total
biscuit who could do that though i don't
know that's keemstar i was gonna say i
could think of somebody here
right
yeah i can think of one person team
store
well i'll say that we have a spot here
that's looking pretty crispy still
and we've teamed up with the pokemon uh
people is that right love you can give
me an announcement that's right yes so
shout out to the pokemon people
to be able to defend your your piece of
land you have to make allies and we made
allies with the people underneath us
i've been told that this is called a
goose i think the animal below us is a
big goose shout out to the gooses people
do we love the gooses do we love pokemon
people oh i think it's medusa doof but
like a dude
sorry about that oh i don't want to
upset the pokemon people now let's get
it right
but they're great friends with us and uh
they let us color uh their background
because we helped them earlier in the
war
and together we collaborated on that
pokemon ball right there
so did the h3 pokeball i love the colors
everything going on here it's sick
it's beautiful and and there's the teddy
fresh communities around yep and that
that by the way i didn't have anything
to do with that just happened
organically amazing don't want to really
plan that it just happened i don't know
how
people are incredible this
this has got to be one of the greatest
like
experiments
in history
of the internet
like it's just and they what happens
like every day they make the canvas
bigger and bigger and bigger
it started as a
1000 by 1 000 pixels so that's a million
pixels and then on the second day they
doubled it to 2 million and then i
believe they doubled that double so it
became four million i don't know if they
then increased it again um
so far
because i remember when it started uh
the logo was quite big i was like oh
[ __ ] now because the canvas
got so much bigger
it's hard to see it when you're zoomed
out but that's a nice plot of land right
there
yeah the french are really claiming
their
their spot down here eh
um
i've been watching the great french
french war yes
yesterday
do you want to explain any drama going
on on our place
love because you've been kind of uh or
ian if you've been following because i
know there's been lots of kind of power
struggles going on on the canvas here
yeah
yeah i think ian might be more filled in
what's going on uh
not in our place like our actual logo
because i've been all about our logo all
the time
um
haven't paid too much attention around
us well you know hassan got pretty
heavily involved uh this past weekend
yeah and
he
his community created a really big
version of his like twitch logo yeah but
i could have warned him he bit off more
than he could chew because they they
took up a big space and the bigger space
you take the more enemies you're going
to make right and it's it's been all-out
war against him because i don't even see
him having a any space on the map at all
is he totally wiped out he he currently
has if you go to total biscuit biscuits
picture
right
uh top left of that you can see his
contribution it's like
it's a it's a cussy
wait where are we
the car that's doing the hego face or
whatever to the top left of that the
yellow car this is his yeah yeah that's
pretty good yeah that's good that's a
fat cussy and i think it that one's
escaped
as much uh
violence again because it's not it it's
people don't know it's him hold on hold
on hold on
who so are these other two cars related
or is there just a cussy kind of
those were placed by the germans
actually and they had to form an
alliance oh man so he put a cussy with
the germans
yeah
oh i love that tank
well that's interesting i like that
contribution well and he had a he had
the bernie in a chair was his community
as well i don't know if that one's still
around it was for a good while uh
it's gone it's gone ah poor bernie the
craziest thing to me like the biggest
plot on this board that's been the
biggest plot by far and the one that's
been under the most contention content
content contention
is the french one how do the french have
such a big presence here they have like
a huge subreddit or something they they
have a streamer who has like over 400
000 viewers oh my god yeah the the
french side of twitch evidently is very
uh bustling and okay
i think it was even a few french
streamers right ian that kind of
bound together there were a couple and
then there was a big uh battle yesterday
because the uh spanish
streamers teamed up with the american
streamers
to do an attack on the french streamers
but france held their own now you can
see those two big purple
lines that's actually the bts uh oh the
the b army is coming in oh yeah yeah
but you better you better put a purple
uh pixel on that bts logo right now if i
was oh i am logged in okay guys
bts
just know i'm with you hit the check you
have to hit the check mark i'm with you
bts there you go perfect is there a
better way to do this love or is it
really just this tedious
well why is your it's not tv your timer
is like a billion years what's that
about
oh it takes me what i can place a marker
and 138 000 days
is that normal
look they no look they just attacked
back
that purple just got a check your email
it says i guess it's not maybe it's
because it's not a verified account
they've put a longer well how did that
happen so fast that's the thing that
happens in waves because they'll do
countdowns on the stream
and they'll be like all right everybody
in three two one that way they can
coordinate the attack wait
i've been wondering how do they how do
they coordinate these intricate patterns
it's books
uh oftentimes it's bots people have
created scripts to to do it but
i mean there's ways to do it without it
too uh like somebody love somebody in
our community designed like a gridded
version of of our logo right that we
kind of used as a template to can you
still hear me we can still hear you your
uh your camera is frozen though so
you're just kind of yeah that's fine
yeah so we've had a lot of help we have
people making spreadshirts
or spreadsheets sorry
so there's a color for every coordinate
so people know that there's grid images
interesting there's a website called
h3plays.com
uh that shows the exact world somebody's
attacking our logo right now
yeah but i'm surprised what i'm
surprised about the most is why are
people attacking our logo right now love
i don't know dude [ __ ] them there's
always people attacking us
what's going on yes it's it's holding
strong though yeah get the [ __ ] out of
here bro
we got completely wiped out a few times
and then we just rebuilt oh yeah it
looks beautiful
h5 somebody changes to age five oh no
so it seems like our original logo is
gone though
and i'm seeing
people are at like trying to reclaim it
that's what i think that is most
interesting right now
we also had the og h3 logo on here in a
separate area
yeah he's noticed that so is the
separate h3 logo just gone to oblivion
or
well i think someone recently attacked
it but we're fighting back uh if you
click that link that i just sent in the
discord
you should be taken to a place
and there's a like a white swirling
thing do you see that like a white
swerve
it doesn't work for me maybe you can
open it down because i'm using like an
old browser or something
people are saying we were taken out by
dream
dream
what that's what i'm seeing in the chat
what
wait they mean they mean our podcast
logo or our
so dream you really want beef with me
bro there's been a few taking it back
because we we got attacked by xqc at one
point as well because just remember i'm
right i'm i'm taking all this personal
there's a video of uh of xuc executing
his attack on us and also something you
see i'm taking all this personally
no no we don't we love uxqc we don't
mind it's all personal
we're happy that you let us have it back
it's all great
oh wow does he have that much power
on the board we've got like 100 000
people watching a stream and if he
directs them at you you're gone you're
gone we're fine with that happening
that's part of the game it is moving on
it's all personal
oh [ __ ] judge match baby hey love if so
if people watching right now want to
help you guys how how do you recruit
people to join your arm there's a
discord that is linked on our twitter i
just scrolled down a couple tweets um
that's the best place we have about
about eight hundred to a thousand people
in there helping us fight every day
thank you guys
well thank you my friends my loyal
troopers
this is pretty awesome man
and i guess it end when does this end
because
this is nature today this oh wow this is
the late the last push
yeah this is our original logo which
currently has a swirl over it
and that's dream
uh evident i i can't confirm or deny
that intel that intel is coming into us
raw and so it uh
we need to further verify um the
intelligence reports that were in the
fog of war yeah exactly you have to be
careful a lot of disinformation out
there
[Music]
well i think it's awesome you guys
managed to hold on to this
so later today then it will just be
saved and
it'll go down
yep down in history it's actually
beautiful i love the pixel art kind of
want to like
save that
put that on up
something but you guys keep it up man
this is really nice really cool good job
love
yeah good job everyone good job to all
the foot soldiers without without them
we couldn't make this happen of course
some of the stuff on here is insane
though i gotta say the american one's
kind of dubbed
uh that's been a long running battle oh
they actually fixed it so the
uh the u.s flag that was on there had
like
40 more stars than it was supposed to or
something so people kept making fun of
it and then
and then yeah it was getting it was
getting a lot of heat i mean us
americans our reputation internationally
sure yeah they're gonna beat them in the
last couple decades i get it i just like
the artisticness of it
that is the best iteration of it by far
that i've seen it was pretty sloppy
before
but there's some really cool art here
there was one
xqc was doing like a butt and then the
mods came in and removed it right like
you're not allowed to draw like a a butt
i guess they are trying to just prevent
it from becoming all dicks yeah
which
you know
yeah likely to happen
yeah i get that
there you go it's pretty fun pretty
interesting i'd be checking in on it oh
we got a berserker one here dan look at
that clean rip mura
really clean eh looks great
um
there you have it guys
beautiful
who would take over total biscuit though
that's just like some nasty so that's
the that's the void
so there's a group of people
that have like kind of self-declared
themselves as the villains
and it's sort of this cosmic horror
thing where they just periodically
choose an area and they like start to
break through
with
mostly black but then usually it has
some sort of like demonic face in it too
and they like intentionally make it
spread like a like a cancer across
um and like radiate out but then people
always like beat it back so it's just
like is it you know it's all in good fun
i i don't think that
they were targeting total biscuit in
particular
it just kind of happens all over the
place uh at various times
um
what did uh you know
do rest in peace total biscuit though
you know i saw his face on there and it
made me
made me miss the guy yeah what did
keemstar say to him again when he was
diagnosed with cancer i can't wait to
report your death oh you do we have a
sound bite of that
i don't think so oh okay i was hoping
you'd ever
pulled it i'll
yeah pull that
oh no there are we're being vandalized
right now oh the teddy fresh what is it
what is it turning into it says fact
fricked
not like this
well anyway guys there it is
damn one piece is taking a pretty pretty
clean uh spot here
shout out
all right
so
let's get to some topics
rice like for example we have really
important things to talk about by the
way i forgot about our poll
uh 45 of the audience that's watching
went and looked at the uh the poopy that
we posted yeah that's pretty good 55.
we posted the poop
yeah
yeah
for a while 45 of people watching have
looked at the poop so
very good
yeah we have important things to go to
like rice gum laughing like a dolphin
now this now is this a new video
it's from june 1st 2020. yeah
ricegum who famously called ela boring
and dry and said the reason i'm
depressed is because my wife is so
boring
uh this is ricegum and for him to just
speak publicly that i didn't support him
and that was on his nuts
that's what you have to say about
bro how are you even comfortable putting
that on video
like not to be a dick because
i think
people's laughs are precious and they
shouldn't be made fun of to made feel
insecure
i don't think that's a genuine laugh i
don't think he always laughs like that
he's obviously forcing it out of him
right
to just speak publicly that i didn't
support him and that was on his nuts
that's what you have to control i mean
how are you putting that out in the
world
i know although like
that's what you have to say
oh my god come on he's in the circus
he's a circus animal
you guys agree what do you think's going
on with that laugh
definitely forest yeah yeah yeah i think
so for sure look at his face
like
that's what you have to say there's
there's like that meme left you know
we're like [ __ ] boys wait hot
it's like oh
i think that's what he's trying to do
but he has such bad sinus problems he
took it too far yeah
i think you're right too because he he
want
he wants to show how you know cool he is
and that that's what comes out somehow
dude that one
wasn't even that dolphin show back in
the day
uh flipper yeah flip forgot the flipper
ass
flipper flipper they call him flipper
what
i'm seeing people in the chat spamming
to talk to hassan i don't want hassan as
my ally he's getting wiped off the board
and that's [ __ ] up right i love we
don't want hassan for an ally the guy
can't even
you know what i mean
i'm just happy with my little spot
i don't write love i don't want anyone
to i just want to get that little
strawberry you don't want no trouble
yeah i don't want no trouble
we don't want no problem yeah we love we
love we're fine we stan we love
xqc king
hassan
as son needs an ally listen i'm not
putting my neck out for some [ __ ]
bro i just uh i just checked this stream
hassan's in a heated call with the
french so you don't want to who are you
negotiating with the french okay yeah no
you've seen the power that bottom of the
board hell no i i landed in france today
uh so i've been personally talking with
the french today so all peace all peace
i gotta say
you gotta you gotta come to the defense
of your friends man this is [ __ ] up
someone said you know where hassan never
defended us why do i got to defend his
[ __ ] we know that
i don't know i just saw someone write it
and i mean what a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
love is my general i mean i'll let him
call the shots you know what i mean well
if hassan decides to go a little i think
hassan went too big if hassan goes a
little bit smaller
we will be there to help him
um
[Music]
he the man invaded europe during the
winter he invaded russia during the
winter whatever yeah he went too big and
now he's looking to us to bail him out
okay hassan i can't bail you out of
every [ __ ] thing you get yourself
into i got my own problem everything
you're saying makes perfect sense
but it it just doesn't feel right to me
it doesn't feel right to me he just want
the goat
you go pixel into cussy
[Laughter]
people are saying a song community help
the h3 square all right let me talk to
hassan i gotta call him
what's going on in this stream right now
is it really that desperate it's very
chaotic i mean if he's in the midst of
an intense negotiation maybe now is not
the time but should i call him or is it
now is not a good time just to write him
off completely like that here let me
text him
text him text him just see if maybe we
can do
some um
unofficial talks you know back channel
kind of thing
you need our help
on place
okay
so what what uh do we need any uh
oh boy we're gonna lose our spot i'm
just saying because we're gonna be
helping we're getting drawn into a land
war in asia yes we're getting dragged
into a proxy war
you guys we're gonna we can't you can't
fight a war on two fronts this is like
obvious you can't
um well you know
can't wait to report your death
thank you yeah
so that's what keemstar told
totalbiscuit when he was diagnosed with
cancer he said i can't wait to report on
your death cool
and he basically did the same thing to
me when i was in the hospital
when i showed like one little [ __ ] uh
sign of being sick right he's like i
can't wait to report on your death dude
what was that i'm setting up uh the
discord in case we do hop on a call on
him so just so it's ready i'll let you
guys know if i hear from him
but anyway back to ricegum who by the
way is friends with keemstar remember
the axis of evil
oh yeah they're merch whatever happened
to that they still selling that hell no
nobody's buying that i'm just surprised
that didn't sell like gangbusters
so back to uh keemstar's friend ricegum
these are gonna be so good for off the
rail intros
for the track i think you're still
getting paid for the track you never
said nah it's cool i paid you my [ __ ]
you never said in the future
[Music]
you're a lie i haven't made a cent off
you
oh there it is he's wearing axe as an
evil shirt right there still getting
paid for the track you never said nah
it's cool i paid you my [ __ ] you never
said in the future
there it is
evil
we saw some axes of people merch out in
the wild when we went to the clippers
game one time oh for real
yeah
okay now that's interesting tell me
about the person who was wearing it uh
it was just it was in a crowd and i
actually tried to get a shot but they
walked away too fast and was just behind
on their backs did you catch a rough age
short pimply child yeah there you go
short pimply child
shows mom bought it
i haven't made a scent of you
bro
how how do you put that out in the world
dude someone you're so embarrassing dude
is he popular on twitch love i know he
fell off youtube but what's his deal
yeah for a while you came back to twitch
he was super big then he disappeared oh
so he's gone again
he's gone again yeah
the shoe fits wear it
the shoe
um
uh ricegum are you okay bro your life is
sounding like a dolphin off of its meds
i think this is just the end of this all
right yeah that's
dolphin off its meds
okay
thank you
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
what else we got we don't have you want
to do the big fendi i mean we've been
going for a while
so i just want to make sure we get to
the news the good stuff we got jordan
peterson cringe which i love
that's evergreen though it's not uh
hassan just said get on discord ethan he
says he can't see you here we go
getting dragged into a [ __ ] two-front
war
just
maybe just tell him you're trying to
wish him a happy ramadan and then go
i mean i'll hear him out but
he can make his play to our nation
tell them tell them it's me we're we're
friends
tell them look for dan
yeah i'm not honest
i'm not i can't do
discord
while i'm doing the show
this isn't a stream hassan this is a
podcast okay what we do here is elevated
i don't do discord
right guys thank you i mean we do we use
it for the show not me
hassan just said you're such a boomer
you gotta figure out a discord we're on
just tell just yeah i'm on discord it's
dan it's dan we're we're friends i'll
get my friend's list right now i see
hassanabhi bring me into the course
he's in the leftovers discord we could
just go in there dan
so who's fendi
uh
he was nicki minaj's manager i believe
he has his own podcast i don't know a
lot about him i just looked at him
who doesn't have a podcast right
i know when i looked them up that's what
kept coming up podcast host yeah the
door number okay so
this is so [ __ ] funny son fendi
pissed me off with this fake
motivational okay
let's take a look
i've been traveling a lot lately man
wait
that's it or it's just look at the very
beginning yeah
well if you've ever seen a helicopter
take on or off
you know that the truck this the
propeller spins for a long time
but he's trying to act like he just got
off there's no pilot in it either also
that's like a two-person helicopter
that's like a
seems like a personal helicopter
no [ __ ]
the door is closed
hell nah bro
the comment is when you fly
some things are self-explanatory
yeah this is awesome
i think that was the helicopter soflo
used oh i think someone's calling me
what the hell bro
i've been trapping a lot lately man
all right hassan
what's going on what's good
so everybody's saying you need help on
place
oh um 100 i mean
sure
i have i have some smaller communities
constantly attacking my [ __ ] but they've
stopped for now
they uh while i was sleeping or not even
while i was sleeping i think they like
purposely came after my dog fish
the tribute that we made the fish
and destroyed it but
we've rebuilt it so far uh if you want
to know where that is it's near ludwig's
uh kirby
on the top right
hold on like i gotta open it yeah
give me a second here your audio is so
boomer right now what the [ __ ]
don't talk to me talk to dan what is it
too loud or too quiet it's like exp the
exposure is like super high it's
probably not what the audience is
hearing he's probably getting all [ __ ]
up yeah i'm probably hearing something
different anyway look look there is
there is international conflict brewing
okay well listen i i don't i don't know
what to tell you because
i'm pretty happy with our little plot
and i'm not trying to get pulled into a
two
a two front war with you dude like i
wanna know you don't have to it's all
good don't worry about it look
all i was saying oh wait now it's too
quiet i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened but do you see our nice little
spot that we have with the pokemon guys
wait i did not where is it let's see
oh
wait yeah here it is
should i not say oh
love's been the one organizing this and
he's he's very scared it's a really nice
plot of land yeah dude it's [ __ ] up
everyone is like everyone's out for a
[ __ ] murder did you see my cussy yeah
i saw the [ __ ] it looks really good
thank you thank you we have uh we have
like we have different
we basically have like uh different
battalions like different units attack
units uh special operations units uh
divided into five different groups
um
so it seems like he left this is serious
it's not enough oh i know i'm i'm
impressed i'm impressed with the level
of organization you guys so hold on
you've got the cussy and then what else
are you working on
so we have a cussy uh we've also
established diplomatic relations with
germany and so the german uh there's
there's a german bot defense
on the cussy as well germany originally
built their own version of the cussy as
soon as they saw us building the cussy
so currently
uh you know we have uh diplomatic
relations with guatemala karl marx is
carter's uh uh uh doing next to cussy
and germany and the germans are
defending us as well the germans really
the germans have a lot of territory here
yeah they they have mastered the art of
soft power negotiations they are
incredibly diplomatic
and they've been doing a really good job
like you know
they're doing a really good job
maintaining the uh
wait what the [ __ ] why is fish what is
happening underneath fish why is it
black right now so wait
i don't know if you're talking to me or
your stream but no he's realizing that
his
i'm also live uh there's something
there's some crazy [ __ ] happening
underneath us right now
no under not underneath because he
underneath fish
okay so where's the fish where's fish
yeah okay
do you know where the kirby is the kirby
ludwig's kirby it's on like the far
right all the way to the right there he
is uh near supermega
yeah move your mouse up ethan yeah oh
here's the curve yeah there's kirby yeah
right and so i think it's to the top
left of that the fish yeah
it's the two dogs it's the two dogs
right there yeah that's mine and will's
dog there you go my dog to pass away is
my hostile emote and then uh will's dog
so
they're there together um
i love that i don't know what is
happening underneath us though i don't
know why they like built this black
is the void coming in
no no no ludwig is saying that there's a
polish expansion but ludwig is currently
in the process of negotiating i did this
shit's crazy
dude i've been doing this for three days
off it's so much fun
is the community does the community and
the audience like it like is your
viewership good when people they get all
into i know my viewership enjoys it
because like we're it's a great
opportunity to like uh get everybody in
and work together
sure you know this jour you know i've
been looking at the french spot but the
germans have kind of secretly might have
the most space
on the whole map with that huge cross
section yeah
yeah are you worried about german
aggression yeah germans know a thing or
two about living space that's what i'm
saying like uh no they
yeah no they we don't want german living
space yeah
but but to be fair to be fair to them
like because you know i i have a line
with them like it's world war one you
know what i'm saying right uh
uh not two right the ottomans
turkey did not align with germany world
war ii but world war one yeah and that
that actually ended up being really bad
uh for turkey regardless but
but yeah world war one there was an
allegiance all right uh group one fishes
being attacked by white ducks for no
our signals are being jammed our signals
are being jammed
yeah there's just like some random
unnecessary attacks happening here
people keep trying to [ __ ] with our h3
pokemon board and i'm just not it's just
not cool
well anyway hassan since i've got you
here
we can now make the joints hold on i'm
getting i'm getting uh in front attacked
currently but if you want to help you
can help with the custody or
we need we need to defend our own
territory you guys why is there white
dots
hassan has four battalions to
do the cussies and the dogs i mean i
just look at us i i just want to hold on
to this one spot right love you're the
general you're my five stars it's only
white right now wait wait something's
going on you can only you can only do
white spots right now
love you command the army you're my five
general wait something is happening
something oh oh
what's happening they're only allowing
whites they're only allowing whites oh
my god reddit reddit itself reddit yeah
oh no they did the uh is this the april
fools
oh no is it upon us this is the purge
don't click stop clicking oh this is the
end time we're in the end times now wait
hold on i gotta talk to ludwig real
quick i don't know what the [ __ ] going
on hold on one second stop clicking
is this the april fool's joke that it
all turns white
maybe maybe this is just the finale
because last but last
because we are getting close to the end
i think it ends in one hour oh [ __ ]
cause long okay this could be the end i
think this is the end my friends
[Applause]
oh no
no hitler wins again oh
it's like the white flag when the when
the atomic bomb goes off no oh my god
look at france holy [ __ ]
france is getting nuked this is actually
pretty cool to be watching live damn yes
wow france is getting bye-bye
oh my god it's all going all going
everybody's work
well if this really is the end i feel
like we can feel good we we lasted to
the end it's true we made it good job
love and troops yeah thank you you call
that a good job every type of victory
well hold on oh my god france just got
totally annihilated
we need our troops to be ready though
because they might put the colors back
on right at the end so we need everyone
to be ready
ours got annihilated too
can't wait to report your death
oh that's such a great sound bite damn
rest to the h3 podcast on our place wow
but sweden is still holding strong
though i'm happy about that
wow it's tragic poor french man wow
first out always always knocked out of
the wall doesn't matter they're always
the first out
oh brutal was true then and it's true
now
very sad freedom fries baby
very very sad
[Music]
um
everything else seems like relatively
fine just france and us
i wonder if it's just the way to counter
bots
from
oh
because then the bots would
automatically like they wouldn't notice
and they would keep going and they would
just start adding white wherever the
bots are active
and then just turn it off after some
time interesting interesting theory
but just the theory is going straight
like white like crazy right now
yeah everywhere oh man it's all gone
i think it's i think it's the end
i think it's end of life
we just got thanos snapped well let's
let's talk about some stuff
poor hassan he disappeared he was like
i've got an emergency meeting with my
generals i gotta go this whole country
he's still on the call but i i assume he
switched over to a different uh
i was just ready to
[Laughter]
to announce the glorious return of
leftovers
oh right well and uh he had to run and
damn france is gone yeah that's crazy
not a single pixel on the board
they made a lot of enemies
and it
not a surprise it's the biggest thing on
the board that's what i was saying is
like
when you go big
you draw a lot of attention but i think
the white death is going to spread from
here yeah
the primordial white death
well let's check back it's like making
it's like shaking the etch sketch after
making the mona lisa on there you know
what i mean
all right interesting times we live in
guys
so big fendi
caught fake stunting as they say
i don't think there was really murder to
that story i just thought that video was
pretty funny funny
and then we've got here uh
oh my god i almost wish hila was here
for this because i had found this and
put it in for friday because i thought
she would really enjoy it oh no
hobby horsing allows enthusiasts to act
out their fantasies of owning riding and
competing
with their own horses minus of course
the high expenses
during helsinki equestrian festival at
the end of may
over 5 000 people
took place in this event
so this is hobby horsing
[Music]
definitely can't
do the audio right i think no it's i
think it's some royalty-free [ __ ]
you you tested it
we tested i think we tested on friday
it's not even good music it's just
annoying anyways but whatever so but why
is it dark
like
it's like got that weird black filter
okay there it goes
okay so this is people with fat with uh
oh my goodness how is this like riding a
horse in any way
[Laughter]
what do you call these things it's like
a horse stick
or a toy
yeah i don't know
okay
toy horse toy pony so it's a horse head
on a stick and there's people they're
the ones jumping
i mean it's not at all like riding a
horse when it goes in slow-mo like
dramatically
whoa
why why bring the horse just do the
just be an athlete be a gymnast
oh
that was a good jump
there's actually a lot of people here
man
so
if you can't afford to own a horse which
is understandable it's very expensive
sure yeah
this is definitely the next people come
out and come compete
i mean they're young right they're all
kids so that's okay
it really gets weird when the uh
30 year olds come out yeah
uh they're called hobby horses by the
way apparently that's why it's called
hobby horsing because i feel like i have
one of those as a kid but i never yeah
we had one yeah okay
is it possible to grow up well adjusted
if you do this
i don't know
i'm afraid not
this is in finland by the way which
does um i mean that's in scandinavia
right i love so that's kind of in your
neck of the woods so what do you what's
your take on this
uh i mean
with peace and love this is kind of
weird
and i mean look how seriously they're
taking it
yeah that's kind of what makes it worse
right
because it would be
ironic in a weird way it wouldn't be
cringe but now it's just super cringe i
don't know
if they were just doing like a gymnast
routine and jumping and stuff
maybe i'm being too judgmental
i mean when the people that are hopping
over the hurdles or whatever sure i mean
uh it's a little goofy but that takes
some uh
some physical uh ability definitely i
definitely couldn't do that um the ones
that really get me are the ones that are
they're prancing around and like
replicating
right is it like dressage is the the
sport where it's just about like the
horse prancing in like a certain way or
whatever
um the people doing that yeah that's um
oh [ __ ] it's happening
dude
people are starting to write and white
it's the white void it's the inverse
void it's happening
are we totally off the map here love
not quite we can still see some remnants
yeah i want to say that everyone be
ready for anything don't use your white
if colors come back we need to be ready
so don't use your color keep the warhorn
please
go ahead oh yeah
we need to be ready for anything
anything
[Laughter]
i mean he's got a point love is love
making he's making good points love is
listen don't use your white guys love
can i can i have the rank of major can i
be a major
sure
you're you're no major dumb [ __ ] yeah
you could be like a fourth star general
i just
i kind of like to the the title major
just a major major thing it's pretty
cool you know
i don't really want to be a general it's
kind of cool yeah
wait what am i
you're a general you're the only you're
the fighter
you're definitely talking to work
yeah you're my right hand man
thank you
damn
people saying to refresh the page i i it
does seem to be functional i don't know
why people are saying it's yeah yeah i
see it spreading i see yeah
it's all happening live right now yeah
this is really happening now here i'll
refresh it though for you guys
oh i'm so hungry
poor guy
so dramatic music
so um
oh ab can you pull up that clip it's
from i think my strange addiction
she's addicted to pony play i wanted to
show that oh my god
she she like comes out to her aunt or
something in the backyard and she got
like a
what one of those things in her mouth
and she's all in leather it's crazy it's
awesome
that's a classic i have it do you want
me to vote for you yeah no no
send it wrong send it raw baby
that's how we do it
also uh there's a new keemstar tweet
about you okay
yeah
let's see it dumb [ __ ] a b
oh god we gotta talk about he talked
about you and the fight we gotta do that
too man
um here is
this
this is what this is what happens when
they get a little older
somebody and
somebody
somebody
somebody in third life has that exact
avatar
[Laughter]
oh
god
is it it's called third life or second
life
second life is that game yeah this is
this exact avatar
that's that that's
that's your brain on pony play
[Laughter]
just that shot of her like that's just
so proud of me and val
i mean god bless her though you know no
yeah i guess anyone who's willing to
live with your hobby absolutely that
openly no problem but it's un undeniably
funny just dance
what did what did keemstar say oh no a
new one
oh [ __ ] did he really edit it to make me
look more sick the photo wait did he do
it again yeah he did it
for maybe more yellow looking into it
[Music]
let's pray for ethan my youtube friend
what do you mean your youtube friend
you're watching the show
just admit you're watching this you
watch the show every day
his youtube friend is brantley
my dear friends told me history is in
diapers now
and from non-stop diarrhea and he's been
spreading feces around his office
and even in his mouth to the point where
he got a bacterial infection
okay
that's i know we're anti-keemstar here
that's basically what i said it's
not an inaccurate tweet
no it's totally i mean i'm not wearing
the picture though
yeah you're not wearing the diapers i
have never worn the diapers
everything else is accurate though
can't wait to report your death
the image obviously
color tweaked a little bit to uh make
you look like you have just so
interesting that he does that yeah
isn't he 40 you just turned 40 right
i okay [ __ ] i don't know if he's 40 yet
i think this year i think he's 40. yeah
he turned 40 and he had like that oh he
went to
had like dave and buster's
the basement nobody came and then he
went uh
cool
keemstar shut up
he said you're [ __ ] goon awesome
shut up [ __ ]
that guy hates him so much like the way
he says [ __ ] it's like he hates
keemstar
visceral it's just [ __ ]
i mean
what the hell dude he knows
uh anyway
beautiful
let's talk about the boxing match
because we're running out of time
ain't so a b is boxing
it's finally been announced
the tickets are on sale right amy
yeah you go to creatorclash.com
creator clash creator creator creator
creator
class
the creatorclash.com
the creator
it's all for charity which is [ __ ]
awesome
so cool
um
and so what what are you what are you
buying like tickets to go there in
person
tickets to stream you can buy already
yeah there's an early bird special right
now to stream the event the actual
tickets to go in person will go on sale
at the end of this week hey i wonder if
we should all get together and watch it
if like all the guys should get together
maybe you guys want to come over my
house and watch the event we should we
should stream it illegally yeah i know i
thought about that i'd be great
you think he you think items would mind
if i just rebroadcast it
how much is a ticket 20 bucks great
um
i i feel like some of us should go
well yeah we can document it well lena's
going right of course but yeah i mean
like somebody from somebody else from
the crew as well with some cameras and
audio gear like
well how much how many more people do we
need abe than than just you and lena
well the thing is i don't know if i'll
be able to see you guys like right
before the event i mean i would love for
you guys to go but i don't know if i'll
be able to see you until like
after well lena will be with you right
yeah and she'll be filming
i
you could
you better be that's the whole point
right
i feel like i'm going to be a nervous
wreck the whole time but oh [ __ ]
but if we sent a cameraman he could be
with you everywhere no maybe that's what
i was wondering like they won't be
allowed in your camera page
to be honest i don't know if i want
anyone with me right before oh
well he's got to get in the zone he
doesn't want to get anything about
content that's fair yeah
i would love for you guys to go i'd love
for you guys to be there
um
this is a serious
this is a serious baby's fighting for
his life in that ring
we've all seen that guy hund this or
whatever his name is
hodor
[Music]
i'm really curious i don't know because
dr mike is a beast
and he there's videos him boxing
apparently he's been boxing for years
can you pull up a video of dr mike
boxing because i'm scared for ian bro
like go in i'm rooting for you
sure
well i i gotta say though doctor i'm
sorry uh ian and his wife anita like
they got their [ __ ] down like they
they have been practicing hard and both
of them like i'm very impressed how much
they know in a short amount of time well
that's great
dr mike says his ass been boxing 10
years dude now do you think that's like
10 real years or like i just punched the
bags here and there
i'm i'm not sure that one video i know a
video talking right now i'm trying to
find a good time stamp
well i'm actually really interested okay
i'm excited for your fight i'm excited
for eight for uh idubbbz fight
here here's dr mike
training let's see
i'm gonna be putting dr mike through the
wire
he says he's been trained for 10 years
we're about to put that to the test oh
this is a trainer
oh he got like a real this this guy's
training him yeah this guy's like a
serious boxer right yeah
i think a lot of them
are doing that though
i don't know and again maybe yeah
absolutely no about a b is a good ass
dude i've been boxing for 10 years ever
since my mom passed away and it's been
such an incredible listen to this
watching all these youtubers start
boxing has reignited my passion for the
sport let me show you how hard i've been
trading
bro ian is gonna
die i love ian great guy
good friend brian garcia thomas what do
you think and you're going to miss him
you're going to miss him i'm going to
bury i'm going to bury him and av in the
same
i'll make it so make sure it's nice and
deep so you guys don't get scavenged by
uh wolves and [ __ ] no in all honesty you
learn quickly size is not everything in
boxing it really isn't it comes down to
technique endurance there's a lot more
that goes into it i thought guys bigger
than items
ian definitely hits a lot harder and he
knows his [ __ ]
i'm rooting for it i'm rooting for you
both
thank you oh those are blame
how's he gonna knock him out he's look
at these who what's he punching a a
mouse
it's funny with no sound okay doctor
mike chill who are you gonna beat up
like this a two-year-old
[Laughter]
that's pretty funny no
it is funny i mean
i know it's hard yeah i know
i know dr mike
well i'm actually pretty interested
though
should be fun it'll be a good fight i'm
i'm pretty stoked so the official date
is
may 14th may 14th
wow that's right around the corner so
wait i'm confused do we need to send
someone there or lena i mean you'll get
some shots av what do you think you're
confident you guys are going to be able
to
yeah i mean and i i have uh like family
those are just gonna go because oh you
do
okay yeah i trust you you guys always
get good shots i trust you
so i mean
i mean i like harley versus egoraptor is
harley's like massive is he going to
kill you go raptor i guess uh
aaron's
a fairly big dude as well
yeah i mean harley is huge harley's
massive bro yeah also like recently he
got super jacked
because he used to be kind of a chubby
boy
really did he oh yeah he got super into
fitness he was like he's like jacked
last time i saw him i am a little
worried for aaron then because i don't
think that he's jacked
but um he's got that game he's got that
gamer bod
um well
it'll be it'll be interest michael
reeves is gonna crush his opponent
that's all i know michael reeves has got
that killer instinct
well this is going to be fun i'm excited
for this event abs been putting in all
the work you can imagine the man is
training his butt off
for a good cause
we support you
we will be watching and cheering you on
and um we actually have been
crowdfunding for a
for a better life insurance policy so
that lean is well taken care of yeah
either die or suffer uh debilitating uh
injuries where you can't work for
the rest of your life i appreciate that
yeah i appreciate that
somebody said of course you know
somebody in the chat said aaron is a
fighter and aggressive harley isn't
though has has he fought before do you
know maybe what i'm not sure i don't
know anything about that wait he's a
fighter
i mean i don't wanna all right i'm
watching maybe yeah okay this actually
these two lineups look sick though
there's one that uh
maybe are we allowed to talk about the
ones that that didn't work out
uh
because there was one in particular i
was really excited for that isn't
happening now and i'm very sad about it
but just say it well well i don't know i
don't want to if it's against the rules
just say it
okay i'm not sure who he was we could
let's not say who he was fighting but
yeah you could say who dropped out if
you want anything for views dropped out
and who was he gonna fight fight
abby just said we're not we shouldn't
say that because that that person is
still in and their their new opponent
hasn't been announced yet so i doubt
that that would have been a good fight
just because he's not in great shape
i was just looking forward to seeing his
get his ass
yeah
i guess that not anything for views i
mean he dropped out
oh yeah
he got an injury i guess
oh that's too bad
anyway
anyway yeah it's exciting but uh
keemstar when he was talking about it in
his announcement video he skipped over
me
okay so let's look at that yeah yeah
it's right here
so keemstar has been the place
so sad keemstar has been excluded from
the event
because literally everyone hates him
surprise surprise he's like but i'm the
punch happy guy me and fousey want to
want to host this
uh
skipped over so he's calling
let's see
he announced it on
dramaalert
financial youtuber versus reeve we have
ryan supermega versus to be announced
and another creator we just didn't have
enough
time to make a poster for him known as
the wizard of oz so listen up dude i
can't believe he actually took his time
out to make that like the amount of
people that would even get that joke
it's like our audience
he's making fun of my wife but he he
whenever i first posted a picture of
lena milina did a live stream one night
and she said she didn't like this
picture because it made it look like a
witch and then keemstar started to send
me pictures of the wicked witch of the
west
uh all summer long and so yeah he made a
joke that only his um my audience or h3
audience understands so
uh
yeah i don't know what brett did to
deserve that i mean if you want to leave
me out i don't know why you would leave
brett out like i don't know what he did
to you
wow we have ryan
he's like listen if lena was 17 i could
totally get with her
and super mega versus to be announced
and another creator we just didn't have
enough time to make a poster for him
known as the wizard of oz
jesus bro that is
not the wizard of oz by the way that is
the wicked witch yeah
that is a totally different character
yeah has very little to do directly with
the wizard of oz by the way our place
going white it's happening
i don't think there's any coming back
from this one love but who knows
who knows but yeah i do think this is
the end unfortunately damn all that work
man i we we never even heard back from
hassan the man went full panic i don't
think we hung up on him he just
disappeared oh i i eventually
disconnected he did but like 20 minutes
later yeah yeah
no he got it yeah
uh hassan's got to have sex with grimes
it's the only way to put
elon in his place man
i saw yet
what i'm serious inappropriate come on
how's that inappropriate
i mean the man just that he's out of
control
also isn't grimes uh dating chelsea
manning of all people oh she's taken i
didn't know that yeah
[Laughter]
maybe that's just a rumor or something i
i don't know for sure i did see that i
don't know anything about it but
i do think it would be
cool if hassan you know a consent if
they both decided that it was in their
best interest to have sex
and then maybe even get married
and his son could be ash ex-711s
dad
i mean that's the only [ __ ] way to
deal with that man did you hear that
that elon bought nine percent of twitter
or something yeah and i saw
who was it somebody some youtuber
tweeted
like immediately like
hassan's twitter is about to get deleted
yeah exactly you'd be like i bought
twitter for free speech and then all of
a sudden just immediately hassan deleted
oh is noelle
miller
just saying
so he called uh
you called out uh there's more uh
keemstar updates here
oh so a b tweeted out
this fair and unbiased news channel
didn't mention i was in the boxing event
because he hates ethan
and then he's responded cry probably
no specifically though abe didn't he
unblock you respond cry and then
re-block you yes
which is what he did to me
all summer 2020 when he was making fun
of lena send a picture he blocked me so
he's just following you on like a second
account
it's one of his goons probably
the [ __ ] dude
he's so embarrassing
i mean
to
who's he doing this cry for i don't know
it's so embarrassing to him i don't know
if he thinks he really like gets under
my skin because i crack up when i see
this [ __ ] it's just embarrassing for him
i kind of don't want to tell him that
because
it brings me so much joy but well the
best is is this in the dark ab you the
other day
where all these sound bites of of keem
saying [ __ ] ab or whatever came from
yeah there's they're getting there okay
okay all right good because this [ __ ]
was so funny
it's awesome man but look how much
attention he's giving you like he
you know
he's building you up bro
how much life he's giving you
that's my boy
yeah
he's your biggest hype man
uh twitter space this was i guess some
twitter space made to talk about the
boxing event
and uh keemstar was this is a long clip
am i meant to watch this whole one i
mean you could cut it whenever it's it's
literally all gold it's all about me
that's the longest one
off about uh me and our ab and my dick
apparently which she's speaking about
many times the last time you talk about
my dick really did not work out yeah i
was surprised he's going there again
yeah he'll talk the man is more obsessed
with my penis than my damn proctologist
art what's the penis doctor called
ice
the man is more no that's the ass doctor
yeah that's what i thought what's the
penis doctor i don't know what a penis
doctor's calling
is it really
no no yeah that doesn't make sense
i thought maybe proctologist is caulking
well there's a urologist the neurologist
specifically
okay urologist
the man is more obsessed with my [ __ ]
than my urologist
i tell you i tell you keemstar if you
like it so much have it oh and i before
we watch this clip i should explain that
keemstar and everyone else in this
twitter room assume that i'm listening
what happened was i joined this room
on my way to the gym it didn't start yet
i went to the gym and i didn't hear any
of it so he's losing his mind and i'm
not in the chat that was what i was
referencing because i thought that was
the funniest [ __ ] ever that just your
icon being there in
the
the twitter space was just sending him
to a [ __ ] property he's convinced
you're listening the whole time yes yeah
and you're just happily training away
i have no idea what's going on and
keemstar is just dreaming of my [ __ ]
as usual
love it here we go
i was going to say that we also have
someone on the creator clash uh
card a b from the h3 podcast in here
right now listening
yeah i mean
yeah that's like just basically a shout
out to get this weirdo in here that's
talked a bunch of yeah weirdo who's he
calling weirdo
how old are you lena oh sorry i
shouldn't ask that but what you guys
the point is
you guys get the point you don't have to
answer that lena
that's okay i'm 28. yeah you're
twenty-eight
and you're in you're 30 right ab
yeah so that's like two years difference
right
right respect all right okay just
checking respectable uh norms good
normal totally yeah
now abe if you were 30
and you were dating like a 15 year old
that would be about the age gap we'd be
looking at between
no that's far too small still too small
yeah you're right you're right he's 40.
so you you be so lena theoretically
you'd be about 10.
yeah that's closer yeah no that's on
ironically that that's more of the age
gap that we're looking at here with
keemstar
and his significant others yeah but only
two years right you guys said two years
yep not 15. not weird i don't find that
weird
this dude was crying because i didn't
cover him on drumler he literally said
oh you're supposed to be fair and
balanced
go [ __ ] yourself you stupid piece of
[ __ ]
oh he's so angry
but it's funny because he acts like he
um like forgot to mention it or
something and didn't like go out of his
way too
yeah dude he's so mad oh my god you guys
you run your mouth slandered
like are you kidding me like i don't owe
you [ __ ] [ __ ] off anyhow why does he
love the word does he know what slander
is no he says it all the time what's the
slander like one example
just one example he well he always says
i slander but he never says well one
just
just one
instance of slander
i mean i have an instance of slander if
kim started saying that i stole money
yeah that's the real irony and then like
when was it out there constantly like as
if it's just a fact that everybody knows
but it's like
what have you said about him that's
slander never i've never slandered him
you know ever i would never do such a
thing no no no you don't understand this
[ __ ] has put up so much fake
[ __ ] about me like
and those fans over the h3h3 podcast
like they're not your normal fans like
they [ __ ] sway you doc what get out
of here you [ __ ] goon
shut up whiney [ __ ] boy shut the [ __ ]
up
l
like you're not hurting my feelings but
like you they went after my family dude
he's mad because i tweeted pictures of
him of the wizard of oz and i like
trolls
hunt into like literally
assuming that the pit the witch the
wicked witch to the west was his wife he
made the assumption right so i got this
dumb [ __ ] a b literally calling
his wife a witch i did the same thing to
his uh did he he
this man is unbelievable his daddy over
there who he sucks ethan kline i sent
him
and then you got [ __ ] ethan klein
sitting there saying he's calling my
wife a horse [ __ ] i didn't say nothing
about your wife you made that assumption
so i told both these fuels
they're [ __ ] upset
they're mad they're trying to harass me
everyone around me
it's interesting that anytime we come up
he has to grandstand with this whole big
story about how they called their
wives
which is like aren't you supposed to be
talking about the boxing event talking
about a boxing event yeah if you were
not like plugged into this youtube drama
and this guy was like rambling about
this you'd just be like what are you
what was your voice what are you talking
about yeah yeah mind you no one knows
who the hell i am our audience that's it
no one knows i'm not a big youtuber and
the other people in the chat try to move
on and he keeps coming back to me like
dude no one knows who i am but i
appreciate you trying your best it's
just it's always what he does it's what
happened in the aid and ross thing and
we saw the result of that it's like talk
about the boxing thing man you're doing
six minutes
of commentary about me and abe
oh this is me spliced it up too this is
i took a lot out
my family and at the end of the day i
don't owe you [ __ ] on my [ __ ]
platforms go on your platforms and say
my name because i could only mine [ __ ]
i could only imagine a b right now being
in the gym and then while you're just
going in on him he's hitting the bag
harder
no he's not hitting the back
he's hitting records he's actually not
even listening which is interesting
so who recorded it baby
uh after i left the gym i had a bunch of
messages from my dad and cameron and
everyone i recorded it after the fact
mm-hmm
dude it's not that hard you do it like
every [ __ ] you literally just showed
up yeah liter literally anytime a a
light breeze hits you
you talk you think about my [ __ ]
i wonder if he thinks [ __ ] is working
today
hmm
that's a nice day
i wonder how chubbed up ethan's [ __ ] is
right now
it's coming up you should see how he
leads into it
what a beautiful sunny day i wonder what
kind of sensation ethan's feeling in his
[ __ ] at this minute
that's his job this week
no
this guy's job is literally to ride my
dick his entire job the reason why he
got hired is to [ __ ] screen cap my
tweets to listen to everything i say to
clip any stream i'm on that is literally
his job is to ride my [ __ ] dick
i will only box one person and that is
ethan klein so you know if you want to
go on this lie that i
disrespected and insulted your [ __ ]
wife for over and over and over again
fine defend your wife in the ring me
versus you ethan klein make it [ __ ]
happen
realistically ethan if ethan saw you on
the streets what would he do like
realistically nothing nothing of course
i would do nothing why oh i'm not gonna
i don't care
yeah of course
that's the correct thing what would you
do like these guys would do anything you
[ __ ] tough guys
like you've seen what [ __ ] uh
what's this homie's name who's shaped
like a [ __ ] donut roll
keem's friend yeah the
what's his name the dude is literally
the guy the guy like the globe what's
his name
what i say we don't even say his name to
be honest but anyway these guys are all
like yo what would you do if you saw him
on the street it's like bro you would
roll down the street you can't even use
your legs bro i've seen that shape like
what are you what are you gonna do
acting all tough
nothing nothing so why is he acting hard
that's what i'm asking i'm not acting
hard oh my god it's not hard to
mock you
it's not that's not acting hard these
people are so weird their their
framework for the world is so weird
here's this response you gotta listen to
it okay here we go
i don't know why he's acting hard but it
would be acting because he's also said
that he has erectile dysfunction due to
like some type of medication that he's
taken i'm serious i'm dead
so it would have to be acting hard
because there's no way it's really hard
oh my god
reckon it gets hard over your tweets
at least
semi i don't know
there's the clip go look for the clip i
mean i'm not a b i don't got clips on on
on handy yes you do yes you do you have
a folder on your desktop
right you have a folder on your desktop
called ethan's primes
you're lying yeah of course the clip
he's talking about is me saying that i
lost
some sensation in my
penis from taking antidepressants not
that i can't get hard
or that i have erectile dysfunction
right
you know
but look i mean i have two biological
children
so
so
and and and you know
as far as i can tell keemstar has zero
right by a lot i think his we've we
found out his daughter's adopted or or
actually i don't even know i don't know
i don't know about his family situation
like
i don't think he has any biological
children so
yeah i don't know for sure actually
god bless her little soul
but uh
yeah i mean
the man thinks about my dick quite a bit
you know what i'm saying
hmm
get over here keemstar you think about
my dick a lot buddy when i hop on or
what
about that about to make me act up boy
i'll teach you about ed
yo you want to see yo you want to see
how dysfunctional this thing is come on
over here boy i'm about to make me
make some mistakes but um
you know what
i got my finger on the button right now
yeah you have to make me
lose my mind son
oh my god
yeah
i seen those deep fake sake riding on
those railroad tracks you know what i'm
saying
he bout to make me act up fool boy
why are you so cute when you talk [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying doug
[Laughter]
i need me a man who think about my [ __ ]
that much boy
[ __ ]
you know this [ __ ] pleasing somebody
[Music]
damn my [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] it's so funny it's so easy to
make fun of him
but ethan talking about his dick doesn't
work because of some [ __ ]
anti-depression medic
dude you're saying like oh god so
funny again he's dissing me for taking
antibiotic
depressants so good he's good that's
awesome
so anyway about the boxing match
say that now we've gone off on the phone
we won't be rooting for a b in spite on
query clash
i mean look dude at the end of the day
let me see i think about
let me say this about a b
uh respect to anybody that gets in the
ring and if you do win a b i will
applaud you like anyone else like good
job you know at the end of the day i can
separate you know
my personal differences and look at the
sport of boxing and you know give you a
clap but when it comes to like promoting
you promoting your boxing a match like
talking about you and your match like
other than me talking [ __ ] i'm not gonna
say anything nice like i don't [ __ ]
like you you're a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] off
it's two in the morning
it's two in the morning i don't know
what that was from that that's me i'm
fast forwarding times 20 to show you how
it keeps coming back okay yeah all right
i'm [ __ ] amped up now talking about
this [ __ ] abp
again let me say it one more time as an
athlete
you know a watcher wait did he just
refer to himself as an athlete no me
okay if you win your event i'll applaud
you because it is what it is takes balls
getting [ __ ] ring respect to anyone
that does it but like outside of the
ring go [ __ ] yourself
is he fighting uh hendor what's the
guy's name like pandora honda yeah like
like that dude's built like
credit to him he
put his way he don't have his opponent
thank you guys for everyone coming out
and a
that's the luck but i hope you get your
ass knocked out see it
yeah
peace out
might drop keemstar man
mic drop more like i'm about to drop do
a [ __ ] drop on kim's [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah this man
[Music]
man thinking about my [ __ ] about to heal
this ed
[Music]
what have i done
no i didn't criticize his genitals or
anything
what we got to strike
the last time we got a strike hell i
need a week off
at least i'll have an excuse
well you know he's trying
the last time we got a strike
was because keemstar wrote an email
to youtube and tweeted at them
complaining
that i s what happened and i'm not
saying this because i would never say
that right guys
is i said something about
that he you know
i see can i even say what i said yeah
let's not yeah
let's not
not uh but i know
whoa whoa i wouldn't i never said
anything like you know yeah let me say
this oh hold on okay let me say this
hold on here here's a banana
okay
now if this banana
were to reproduce with another banana
and then it started crying during the
act of reproduction
and i said that about the banana
and the banana wrote an email to youtube
and you said you have a tiny
and you have a tiny [ __ ] the banana
and then the banana wrote an email to
youtube
and said
hey ethan said those specific things
that i just mentioned about this banana
then theoretically i would get banned
for saying those things about the banana
i didn't say those things and i wouldn't
ever say those things these days after i
got banned
that's good you learned your lesson
you know bananas reprodu
oh my god boogie posted a apology video
apparently
you can't do it
um i just saw a comment about it yeah we
should uh
probably wrap it up since you're a sick
boy we've been going
almost two and a half hours so let me
just make sure let me close this let's
check on our place
oh my goodness you guys look at that
yep
well there you go they did it man they
really
they threw a wrench in there eh
yeah they sure did
last year
it was just
did they do something similar i don't
think so last time no right i think it
just ended right unlocked
interesting i think
are you upset about the way this ended
love
no i mean it's pretty rememberable um
we're we've still be like i think it's
cool to just be there
where were you
exactly yeah i kind of liked that the
impermanence of it and that they just
kind of let it all drift away
you know the a3 logos will be on all the
time lapses that's going to be shown on
this
like for all the coming years yeah
we we were we were there basically we
were there baby
so does it end at like 5 p.m or
something in like 20 minutes
i think so yeah or maybe they're going
to it's like old white i don't know
i bet they'll take a snap of this or
whatever this is because it makes sense
because it started as white so when you
watch the time lapse it's going to start
white and then slowly materialize into
all this art and then at the very end
it'll kind of wash away into white again
yep
uh let me check the dock
um
there was keem saying he's offended that
he has to keep talking about a b on his
platform
brantley calling brantley calling out
elo which we heard
keemstar
uh is offended
oh [ __ ] dude we have so much good stuff
you guys like
[ __ ] ryan cavanaugh did we ever talk
about his editorial he put out about
wickedness no no he didn't i think we
should wait though because
you said that there's a new um yes
declaration from him and so he had to do
like a whole ryan thing on wednesday
well ryan did you ever hear back from
from them
no
no
no response at all
[ __ ]
yeah
i will say i i think amy's a good guy i
think you know you deep down
i think you can be a good guy so i think
both of you need to get together so we
can all see how simple you can i also
think like yeah if he was on here with
keem it would be entertaining but kim
isn't fighting a b
you see i'm saying that's where kingston
like where's the entertainment if it
yeah what is what is what is my
motivation like i'm almost offended that
i have to keep talking about him on my
platform like it's for happy punch
but aren't you are you
helping not be
curious about like
what coach he's training under what his
you know what his nah
that's that's my opponent bro i don't i
don't like defending me i don't care
like oh that that's like honda that was
speaking yeah honda and dad were both oh
yeah
what is my motivation like i'm almost
offended that i have to keep talking
about him on my platform like it's for
happy punch
he's training under what his you know
what his so that talking is abey's
opponent who is a great guy by the way
you know great guy love the guy
yeah he's a really nice guy
stand-up citizen
you're not enough no i don't i don't
i don't care like you know what i mean
like i don't care anyway i wonder
if ethan's gotten off today
[Music]
god
i really don't care
dude what about what about this guy
this guy played a a huge role in like
trying to ruin my career like he wasn't
effective at all him and his boss over
there what is he talking about
what is he even on about
i had no [ __ ] idea
[Music]
that was a long time ago
i was that was
all us
well us prior to ab being an employee
yeah
yeah yeah no av didn't have anything to
do with that
i mean they try every week to spin some
weird new [ __ ] narrative to try to
cancel me and they fail over and over
and over again so it's like you have
someone that's trying to like
rip you down and trying to cancel you
and like shut down like you're
ah dude career nobody's trying to cancel
you're just making fun of you dude yeah
we're just making fun of you bro that's
it
that's it let's eat
if you want to date 18
year olds
you know
if you want to date if you want to make
little
let me just put it this way keemstar do
you check ids in your basement yes or no
you know he don't
what's the chance keemstar checks ids in
his basement i don't know i just
tend to not find myself in situations
where i need to be checking ids for
right the people that are coming over to
my house right
right i'm just trying to don't find
myself in that position right
help him and blow up his like it just
doesn't make sense even this
conversation is baiting me into talking
about him
and giving him
you know so
i was worried i was gonna come on here
and he would be like voldemort for you
or something like we weren't going to
say his name
well he would be like that yeah
i don't want to because i don't
i don't want to because i don't want to
promote him in any way
he's so awesome he actually gives you so
much more attention by doing this yeah
like if he just treated you like a
normal person you would get so less
attention he ends up spending the whole
time talking about you yeah dude even
when you and eli first defended me i had
like 100 followers on twitter and he's
sending me pictures can you imagine uh
someone with two million followers
sending pictures every day of a witch
then blocking me and doing it again the
next day for like two months on end
yeah you have like 100 followers bro
if he just [ __ ] shut up and talked
about you like any other fighter
dude he would have talked about you for
like five seconds and now he's talked
about you for like 30 minutes it's all
he's talking about it's you the whole
fight's about you maybe three days in a
row yeah tossing yourself you stupid
piece of [ __ ]
so shout out
shout out awesome it's funny there's
there's one more little clip i don't
know if you oh yeah i'm here for it all
uh wherever he this is prior to these
ones that we just listened to another
twitter space where oh yes and niece and
i idubbbz who they're most excited to
see
okay here we go
yeah
okay let's talk about which fight
are you two most
hyped for which one are you most tired
for personally i
uh hundar and abe and uh
uh minx and yodeling haley i would say
those are my two graham stefan and
michael reeves will be interesting too
but to be honest honda and a b and uh
minks and yodeling haley yeah
yeah because uh brett and
uh ab have been doing it longer than any
of the other fighters because we got in
contact with a lot of these people in
november
and we basically said like start now
because you're not going to be able to
get this time later and uh brett navy
are the ones who started straight away
thankfully
they're the ones matched up against each
other and they also have uh two very
good coaches yeah um at very you know
good gyms so
exciting though actually just hyping up
the fight
kind of wish you were against someone
who didn't take it seriously you just
[ __ ] him up and that'd be fun
yeah me too
but it's going to be good bro it's going
to be good
how did you get that financial youtuber
involved uh what is his name stefan i
believe graham
graham how did you get him
just how he ignored it he just moved the
[ __ ] on without no comment
yeah
i thought he was gonna launch into some
whole
thing about how don't say ab
involved he takes a wrong hit he's gonna
be giving bad financial advice
yeah oh man
shout out
shout out to the island
well
oh my god mr ed
was that a car crash
no that was a rice gum right
right
all right well we got lots left over
madonna tick tocks that shit's gonna be
weird
we'll have to put a spooky warning on
those yeah
bro madonna kissing drake had me
cracking up
it literally looked like he puked in his
mouth afterwards
like she spit a tonsil stone in his
mouth or something
all right um
let's let's put a pin in it i gotta
actually go uh make a pesto deposit oh
oh
death
well
thanks for watching everybody
it's been fun it's been good it's been
real it's been exciting
it's been ups has been downs
laughs
you know
gaffes oh when it's leftovers coming
back
uh i believe he said it a million times
now yeah but it's good to repeat i
believe the first episode back will be
published on
may
i'm looking up right now just to confirm
so i don't speak i believe it's may 1st
is the day it gets posted yeah uh that's
the sunday people are not loving that
pesto deposit comment yeah
so may 1st uh and i guess the day prior
to that uh for members yeah i'm excited
actually to get back
in the saddle yeah boy
me too
that'll be fun
thanks guys for tuning in
and uh we'll be back wednesday
i'll keep you updated hopefully i'm
feeling better i don't know
[Music]
you guys want me to tweet a picture of
my [ __ ]
no no
no we've done that enough today
okay
once this is enough why didn't kim's the
kim start commenting on my [ __ ] yet
no no no
you don't see anything all right
guys see you on wednesday good night
[Music]
you